hello and welcome to nut redundant
Grosch on one of our partner schools
[Music]
today I had a royal visit here first of
all they went to see some real tennis
then they went to see the chateau at
Versailles
and finally they came here to see us at
the school unfortunately I couldn't
interview them but I thought I'd make a
game of it and see how many creative
shots I could get with them in the
background
take a look
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and here's what our students had to say
about the visit today osteoporosis
college she wears long boots up from a
year ago fast useful ability secure
Valerie to normal more Parkinson to the
Selassie
Lynette it looks a bit for supper to
bathtube
no good a bit because I say a lot of
buses angleterre on that - it's
conservative so-called food booze on
pork there's obviously many dog boss I'm
hungry daddy boss looser so that won't
get you to come for work so I've packed
everything up I'm about to go home see
you next time
[Music]